your adversaries in the Wrights this eve
shall be the accusers whose have our
pile yet burns once the other is
extinguished shall step closer to
freedom now let the rights
commence competitors strive to win
criminals yearn for freedom these
pursuits go hand in hand in pyre the
latest game from Bastion and transistor
developers supergiant games and like
those games pyre and chance your eyes
and ears with beauty at every turn but
it's greatest feat is the unrelenting
pull of its characters a mix of beings
that yearn for salvation revenge and
revolution that isn't to diminish the
refreshing and unusual gameplay which
mixes light RPG elements with of all
things sport
supergiant has seemingly borrowed rules
and maneuvers from football and
basketball to flesh out pyres
three-on-three competitions
matches where exiled criminals battle
for freedom the basic objective is to
cross to the other side of a small arena
and place a ball into your opponent's
goal but the other team can knock your
players off the field intercept passes
or steal the ball from your hands
players can be bigger small tricky or
straightforward but everyone offers
unique abilities and substantial
tactical death perhaps recognizing how
fun and unique these matches are
supergiant games included a local vs.
mode for players who want to engage in
rites outside of the story an
unavoidable desire given how fun they
are and a great opportunity to play as
characters that aren't otherwise
playable during the story
for his tense and exciting in these
matches or rights can be they mean so
much more in the context of peyer's
story like Roman gladiators the
characters you bring into battle are
ultimately competing for the honor of
freedom the corrupt leaders of the
Commonwealth have banished you and
everyone else in the downside to live
out your days and what amounts to
purgatory but win enough matches however
and one person from your team may return
to the Commonwealth for a second chance
at life lose these pivotal rights
however and kiss that chance goodbye
with a fixed number of Rights throughout
the story you only have so many chances
to heed your friends and while it can be
heartbreaking to watch your opponent
ascend rather than one of your party
members there are bigger stakes to play
that weigh heavier as time goes on your
team operates under the tutelage of a
revolutionary figure with plans to
overthrow the Commonwealth and it will
only work if you effectively resurrect
enough characters in your party it
behooves the cause then to put your best
characters forward but sending off
champions is bittersweet you serve the
greater good and given a gift to a
cherished companion but you must also
say goodbye and no matter what
when the final ride passes those who
remain shall live out their remaining
days in the downside with no hope of
returning to life as normal
were it not for pyres elegantly crafted
characters the consequences of your
decisions wouldn't carry nearly as much
weight as they do every exile you meet
bears a unique backstory and personality
and the nine that join your cause stir
up emotions both in you and among each
other
Edwin's unrelenting optimism for example
becomes all the more meaningful when you
understand that it's despite his
constant heartbreak Pamela a cold and
fearsome harpy seems less imposing and
more fragile by the time her complicated
family ties come into view if for some
reason you lose a match when they're up
for absolution you can't help but take
on guilt for failing them in that
pivotal moment by and large these
matches are appropriately balanced
growing gradually more difficult as the
story progresses if they seem too easy
you can raise the difficulty in the
options menu but you can alternatively
elect disadvantages for your team that
in turn allows them to level up faster
win or lose though the game goes on and
you're exiles earn experience towards
enlightenment and get to choose between
a small selection of special abilities
as they level up you can also acquire
talismans to benefit individual care
actors or the team at large beyond who
you take into these rights and who you
converse with during your limited
downtime character progression is yet
another way that Peyer allows you to
personalize your journey in the downside
Pires competitive side is a wonderful
surprise
both for how it introduces a brand new
sport and for how it seamlessly connects
to a narrative filled with heartfelt
characters and tragic circumstances but
it's all held aloft by relentlessly
beautiful artwork and a soundtrack
packed with a diverse selection of
genres and instrumentation every inch of
the world and every second of your
journey is a delight for the senses
[Music]
and thus it's all too easy to fall in
love with pyre it's immediately
attractive if songs dance in your head
long after they debut and before you
know it you find yourself reflecting on
your partners in the downside those who
you trained as well as those you
neglected supergiant has created
something special that lives on in your
heart and against great odds its
invented a sport that could have stood
on its own without the story it's
attached to but it's so much better
because it is
[Music]